samuel
je dois te poser des questions
et voici venir les dirigeants de demain
ce sont les nouveaux donc tu as de la chance
besoin d'un enfant paradisiaque
bonjour je m'appelle samuel j'ai dit le
Garçon
[Musique]
ressemble à un ministre
ces gens n'ont jamais rien de bon
que pouvez-vous me dire à ce sujet pourquoi
Nous pensons que c'est l'arme du crime.
[Musique]
comme vraiment
Je pense que les autres pensent que nous sommes
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on cache aux fashionistas
peut-être 20 pays
c'est que je n'ai rien à avouer
[Musique]
je sais
tu vas être avec elle tu m'entends
quand la poudre rencontre le feu
quelque chose peut m'arriver
explose
qui était
ce n'est pas un point
Avez-vous d'autres questions